Oh
[Music]
you
this is Hillandale USA just one American
town of course it looks like a lot of
other American towns your tongue and
like your town it has its businesses its
homes its cars and its people and
children children just like monsters in
your town and dentists like doc Jenkins
how humans credit
go pretty well thank you
hi dr. Jick hi did you me but there is
something different about this town
something vitally different a vital
difference that at present affects
mainly the children and will affect them
as long as they live
you can't see the difference in their
clothes or in the way they walk or play
you may not even notice it in their
smiles and yet that is where the
difference is in their smiles in their
mouths
inside their mouths you may not see but
the trained eyes of Miss Jones the
dental hygienist can see can see that
something has happened to the teeth of
the young children something that today
is almost a dental miracle
for today Miss Jones finds only one
cavity for every three she found seven
years ago
[Music]
seven years ago something happened in
this town something very simple happened
seven years ago something was added to
this water added to this town's drinking
water
[Music]
it did something to the teeth or for
them and the children's teeth just don't
have as many cavities anymore and here's
how it happened
you're something interesting this
leather but fluoride in drinking water
listen to this a considerable amount of
scientific evidence shows that children
born and reared in areas having fluoride
in their drinking water have fewer
cavities than have children using
fluoride free water this scientific
evidence meant simply that this chemical
would save teeth
our dock chanc ins is in the business of
saving teeth Annie knew what a job it is
to cope with all the cavities and
children's teeth
dark knew that dental decay is the most
widespread of all diseases that there
are literally millions of neglected
tooth cavities
he knew that the average man or woman
can look forward without pleasure to
losing half their teeth before reaching
40 he knew that tooth decay begins early
in life in childhood and at the time to
start doing something about it is early
when children are less than eight years
old six or two years even earlier before
tooth decay has a chance to affect their
health a while he knew of course that
youngsters themselves could do some
things he recognized that he and the
other grown-ups of his town would have
to do a great deal more so doc got all
the information he could about the
then-new idea of fluoridation to save
teeth the facts were exciting and doc
determined to do something about
had dental conventions he began bending
the ears of his fellow dentists
soon full of enthusiasm he got ahead a
most propitious moment the ear of the
mayor coronation and so the mayor asked
interested civic minded groups to meet
with the Town Council to hear the
opinion of experts status physicians the
dental director of the State Health
Department and local health department
people now I'm going to ask mr. Evans
chairman of the fluoridation committee
to take over the meeting mr. Evans
Thank You mayor first of all I like to
call on dr. foster well speaking for
myself as well as other dentists in this
area we are for fluoridation we dentists
are in business to safety not just to
film it
thank you dr. cough and now we're going
to hear from dr. Harris of our local
charter our health department has
received some studies on fluoridation
from the State Health Department the
local health department learned that
children who drink water containing one
part of naturally occurring fluoride per
million parts of water have two-thirds
less tooth decay two-thirds less decay
than children drinking ordinary water
that's why we of your health department
feel that fluoridation merits your
approval I'd like to say time I've heard
it for I will make your teeth look ugly
now we don't want our his teeth to look
bad with black and yellow stains let's
give up the idea he's right and I think
the bones brittle too
but all sorts of things to your health
but here in our state dental director
can say about this Matt those statements
are not right facts in our possession
indicate that there is absolutely no
danger the state dental directors office
had proof that only excessive amounts of
fluoride can cause mottling of teeth and
that hundreds of thousands of people
have used natural fluoride in the right
amounts all their lives without harmful
effects I'm sure the position on this
committee will agree that these people
are just as healthy as people who drink
ordinary water that's exactly right
a great deal of sound medical evidence
suggests that these chemical compounds
will not harm the human system in any
way when used in the recommended
proportions and further will save teeth
and therefore making it easier for US
doctors to preserve the health of the
people of Hillandale I like this
fluoridation idea at meetings of women's
groups PTAs and so on the idea of better
teeth for children with less strain on
the pocketbook add a strong appeal well
we people in the water department are
ready to do the job have you got the
facts in regard to the cause of this yep
so we have gone into the matter quite
fully the low cost of installation and
maintenance was fully explained and then
recommendations were presented to the
people of Hillandale
community-wide discussion started and a
hot discussion it was on both sides of
the question what do you mean fluoride I
like my water cleaner purer not doped up
with a lot of chemicals anything it will
give my kids good teeth and save me
dough boy I'm for that fluoridation
stupid well I tell you this if it's
gonna help of the kid it's a very good
me I oughta know I got a eight yes sir
when Town Meeting time rolled around
again the folks in Hillandale we're
pretty excited I like to ask a question
won't the water taste funny
what will it do to my clothes when I
wash them madam floor I will not color
water nor lethargic or a soft well now
tell me this how is it going to affect
my liver medically speaking it will have
no effect sometimes they put chloride in
the water others they take it out how
come well Jim let me explain that
counted have too much natural fluoride
in the water let's take it out
but towns that have no fluoride they
must add enough to do the job for why I
had the stuff I like my water the way it
is not medicated fluoridation is just
another name for mass medication why you
don't have fluoride to cure a disease
you add fluoride to prevent disease
tooth decay why we've been adding
chlorine to our water for a long time
now to prevent disease no one calls that
mass medic
will it hurt our goldfish or guppy the
amount we propose will harm no living
creatures what I want to know is how
much is it gonna cost me
it'll cost you about 10 cents a year per
person that's just a drop in the bucket
because the fact is every one of you
citizens of Hillandale can pay your
share of 30 years of fluoridation for
the price of filling one and that was
about it
for the people of Hillandale had the
courage of their convictions decided to
pioneer on the strength of the available
evidence even before fluoridation was
endorsed as it is today and only by the
United States Public Health Service but
also by the American Dental Association
the American Public Health Association
and other National Health Organization's
after the Town Council acted well
everybody sort of waited when about
their business as usual but the day the
equipment was installed at the
waterworks now that was the day
some wanted to see the feeder some
wanted to see what the fluoride looked
like how it was weighed and put into the
water and the feeder pump that was
designed to add just one part of
fluoride to each million parts of water
it was a big day for dr. Jenkins that
all those who had fought to put over the
idea some wanted to see the fluoride in
the water
of course they couldn't see or smell it
and they couldn't taste they couldn't
see or taste the fluoride then any more
than the youngsters can see or taste it
back here in the schoolhouse today where
they've been drinking this fluoridated
water for seven years
but as a matter of fact you can see the
fluoride now were dachsies it in the
dental records of the town for the
record show that already two out of
every three cavities had been prevented
in the teeth of the little people of
Hillandale
and you can see it in the smiles of
these children and all the children that
come after them the happy shining smiles
of their own healthy teeth
[Music]